Hello, y. Welcome
to week nine.
I this week, we're
going to go through
the AGH 44 generative AI
for data generation and
assignment to
help session.
I think it's not visible
in your screens.
Let me enable that.
Perfect. We're
going to talk about
the first is how you are
going to generate data,
or how you're
going to locate
data and how you're going
to use generate way
that and then go through
some comment mistakes and
some comment takes for
your assignment two.
And then we would
have our he session h
to come along
and then answer
any questions go through
your answers and
ask any questions if
you have any ques.
Before I go through the
the second part
of the sien.
First, we'll look at
the data generation
and locating
public data ss.
The first thing is a
When you look at
your assignment one,
two, and three,
how they are related is
with assignment one,
you pick your topic
and you do your
literature,
you found your
research questions.
Assignment two is
completely data analysis,
and the w how you
link it to your
assignment one,
and how you're
going to link it to
your assignment three
is by doing this part,
which is the last
two sections
of your assignment two.
There we ask you to
find a public data set
that closely or remotely
relates to your
research topic.
And then we use it
to do the analysis.
In most of the cases,
we would highly
encourage you to find
an actual data
set because you
would see the real
world correlations
and the analysis would
make more sense.
In a worst case
as a last resort,
if you don't find
a publicly
available data set,
then you can use
the generative AI models
to generate a data set.
One of the reasons
why we ask
you to try to find the
real data set is because
when you generate,
as we show in our
next demonstration,
you would be giving
constraint for each
column or each variable,
saying, if it is H,
take variable from,
ten to hundred
and then say give
a nice normal distribution
for the data and
all of these
constraints you
apply for each column.
But the relationship
between columns,
which is what
you get along
when you do correlation
analysis and all,
they would make
much less sense in
generated data because you
cannot define certain
correlations.
In most of the cases,
whatever you see
in the field or in
the domain, would
reflect here.
For example, if there
is a scientifically
if those two
variables should be
directly proportional
to one another,
you might not see
that relationship in
the data gener
generation. Then in some
trends or analysis that
has been done in
the literature.
Also, you might not
see, for an example,
certain attitude for
concrete mixture should
increase its durability
and that has been
consistent over
the literature,
then whatever the data
two roles that you
have for those two
should have a nice
correlation based on
the literature and
the domain knowledge.
But those things you
wouldn't see in that case,
you can include
those discussion in
the interpretation part
of the assignment,
but more or less
try to find a dataset
that is closely or
remotely related.
In some cases, you
might have datasets
like majes or some have
trajectory data
sets where you have
certain variables not
in the tabular format.
In that case, you can
find a dataset that's
closely related to tab
a classic example.
I could think is if
you are using any
image segmentation or
detection of anomalies in
heart tray Iota tray
images or something
like that.
In that case, you cannot
use the images here,
but if you can find
some public data publicly
available dialysis
that has some sensor
measurements
related to heart.
Your heart rate, ECG,
all of those valids
as tabular data.
You do the analysis
on that in that case.
How is going to get
related to your
assignment three?
I'll quickly go through
the assignment three
details page and show you
where those two
things would
coincide in the future.
If I quickly go to
assignments and
then assignment three
presentation slide.
If I go to the details,
You can see
the structure of
the presentation,
you would have
introduction, ate
re motivation.
The is all similar to
what you did one day,
but in a bit of a
more briefer manner.
And then you have
the other sections.
You would go through them
in the following weeks.
But where the data set
mato is number six.
Evaluation methods and
reflection using
preliminary data,
outline your
plan real world
experiment approach
and evaluation methods
including how you would
actually evaluate it.
Focus on demonstrating
the experiment flow
in real world application
of your research plan.
Present initial
evaluations based
on the preliminary data
from assessment two.
In the public or
internet directly,
discuss limitations,
challenges, and
existing in
the current primary
data analysis.
What we expect here
is because you
might you are not
doing your actual
research in this course.
So that's why you have
a research project pitch.
Imagine that you have a
audience of
academic experts,
industry experts,
other resource people?
You are short of
showing showcasing
that this particular
research gap
as and these
particular questions
are the ones you're
going to answer.
As some supporting
evidence as
some supporting
initial analysis,
you show that analysis
there in that
presentation.
That's how the
data generation
links with the
next assignment
that's going
to come ahead.
It's important that you
have this in your head.
If you're generating data,
you know what is
expected and how they
link to each other.
Any questions on these
parts, A play parts?
All good so far. All good.
Perfect. Now
we'll go through
the locating publicly
available data thing.
So in the slides,
The first thing we're
going to do is try
to use General AI
for locating
public datasets.
One of the reasons why
we do this is in Google.
If you just google,
you can give a bit of
a more detailed prompt
in your Google.
You can use the
General AI model here.
Specify what is
your topic and
then give it certain
restrictions so that
it could link you
to give you the links
to some of the datasets
that would be useful.
We'll try out this prompt.
Let me open my co pilot
and then type it out.
I'll sit a new
tack here and then
I'll face the
prompt that I had.
I'll explain the
basically we say I
need help locate it
publicly available data
on the topic of and I put
the topic evaluating
the structural performance
of recycle concrete.
You can replace this
with whatever
the topic that
you're planning
to investigate
and then you can say,
provide me with some data
re description
and the URS.
The data so be strictly
tabular not so
These parts in the prompt
is helpful because
it's going to do
the validation when it
runs and then
it's going to
give you eliminate those
cination, and stuff.
This is some prompting
techniques that we use.
From this, and then
hopefully you'll get
some good results.
It's pointing towards few
doss natural
fibre recycle,
aggregate concrete
dias from man data.
Is another source
from many data.
Another one from
another domain,
so you find a
set of gases.
If I use the first
one, for an example,
You can see here the
data set is here.
And then now if you click
on the data set file,
you can see that, you
can se da sets like this
for your own topic,
pick one and then
start your investigation
based on that.
So that's about
how you located RS
The second part is
in case of where
you don't have
a publicly available
data set that's
close or remotely related
to your research topic,
you will have to
generate a data sets.
We call it generating
a synthetic data
and we use microsoft
Cole this.
Then we have a sample from
tire in the canvas,
you should be able to see
this one in modules. We
nine practical and you'll
find the slides here
and this pro here.
I'll just quickly go
through the front.
You just give a
role to the model,
you say you are a
data generator.
This is one technique
that's used in prop.
If you give a
role, sometimes
you good results.
And then create a
synthetic do set
in CSP on no p,
no marked down
tables, no fences.
The reason why we
say this is because
sometimes when you
say generate data,
the model might
not generate
as a code for you to
ran in by the nom mat
generate the dax We
don't want that.
That's why we just give us
the straight of s here.
Then we specify the
different
characteristics we want
in the dark set.
We set row count.
We usually have
around 200 rows.
We set it up here around
200 because in order to
see some meaningful and in
order to do some
meaningful analysic at,
you need about
100 to 200 rows.
You can set it
to 200 here.
And then you specify
the schema and the
relationships.
If you've done
any computer
database management
or anything,
these steps might be
very familiar to you.
Basically what we do by
schema and relationship
is you define
each of the variables
or the column that you
wont set and you set
up the relationship
in between them
and you say the constraint
in them as well.
So this particular
data set is for
some redable energy
generation data
for different plants in
different countries.
You have a plant ID plant
named country, region,
energy source,
capacity Ma
commission date,
operate ID, and all
these other parameters.
Then you set up
your relationships,
you say plant
ID should be ix
because this is
randomly generating
the values.
You have to clearly
define them.
And then operator ID and
unique operator name
should have a
one to mapping,
meaning that
the person with
one ID should be
assigned one name.
So it's a one
to one mapping.
So we specify that.
And then we say
plant ID should be,
should have these
plant idea should be
linked to these
and energy sources
is a defined set.
I should only contain
values in this given set.
For capacity on
energy sources,
we give for solar
what is the range,
for wind, what
is the range,
for hydro what
is the range.
Here, these values should
be based on the literature
for your topic,
Because you would
know what are
the more sensible ranges
for each of
those variables
based on the literature,
so you can set it up
here based on that.
Then we do the same
for other
variables as well,
generation, C two
savings commission date,
we say it's in
date I Fat Ctr
say we define
the state again
and region consistent
with the country.
We make sure
that one region,
you apply one column
does not get allocated
to another
different country.
They should
have a mapping.
That's what we try to do.
But in certain cases,
when you're
generating data,
you have to again sometimes
manually check or
give constraint based on
the data we
generate because
The classical example
is if you generated
dataset with someone
age, let's say,
you give the
constraint and say
10-20 to 100 or 120,
and then there is
another column
that says years
of experience that
again says 101-30
or 40 and then you
generate the two
rows and then there
might be someone who
is 20-years-old with
a 30 year
experience because
if you don't have
that problem.
That's why we
say it's been
generating since
you are not
defining
the relationship
between the columns.
Explicitly for each cases,
you have to make
sure you define
certain relationships
like this in order to
get rid of those
inconsistencies in the dt.
So you define
those and then you
have the realist
inconsistency part.
Here, you say no
duplicate rows.
Name make them realistic.
Operator IDs,
you give them
a sort of a
format, plant ID,
you give a format,
and operator name,
you give some
examples and ask
you to make it a bit
more realistic, right?
And you define
how good format
say you need a CSV only
with single row and
200 around 200 rows.
CSV means command
separated values,
you ask for command
separation,
no explanation,
no extra text,
and you give
some validation.
These validation rules are
given an end
because it will
generate the answers and
sometimes it runs
the validation
rule by itself.
If you have this sometimes
it depends on the models,
but mostly most of the
models do tack it.
Then finally say
return the CS row.
Simply copy prompt
and then start a new
chat and pass it here.
It's starting to run.
Sometimes based
on the model and
the chat you use.
It will make some
short mistakes.
You have to correct
them in the chat again.
Here it is
generating the data
set as we wanted,
has these rows.
These column headings,
plant ID, plant name,
country region,
and then from
here on the data stuff.
It says f001, Victoria,
solar plant, and all
these vs. It ends
and then when
another PL starts,
for example, here,
the new line starts.
I'll stop this
because it's
creating, generating.
More. Now, one
other issues
that I can plainly see
when I was
trying to locate
the other sets is in
this generated CSV.
You can see after
one plant row ends,
the other plant
starts like this.
If you read it as using
an Excel or text file,
if you copy down, it
might not have the
row separated,
so it will go in one row.
You may have to do a bit
of prompting if you see
something litres
and say correctly.
Lines separate
ration is missing.
Please add it
and regenerate.
So models may even output
an Excel file
for your case.
I generated the CSV.
I think it's opening.
The generated one
is directly doloed here.
You can see synthetic
plant energy.
That's opening from Mu,
you can change to open it.
You get the data set here.
Inspect the data that make
sure everything
makes sense.
The date is not
visible here.
You might have to
change it and then
here I haven't pated
the access able here,
but you can
change the date.
When you put the
right format for it,
you will see the date
in the correct format.
That is an example of
how you generate data.
Any questions
in this part?
A clear. Okay. Thank you.
Now we'll move to
the next part,
which is the assignment
to Health session.
We have a few slides
that we talk about,
some of the common
questions we had from
the last years and some
of the common mistakes
that students
tend to make.
There just plag payment,
some things to be
looked into before
you submit your
assignment.
Once I finish
that, I'm happy
to come to you
and in such an
easier as well so we
both can come to
you and answer
any questions
related as well.
All right. The
first one is
regarding plots. If
you look at the bro
For the first part,
you will have to create a
single boxplot
visalization to
identify outliers across
de way usage data.
One hark is given
if you have
a well formatted plot
and zero if not.
What we mean by
well formatted
is you need to name
the axis properly.
You have to have the title
and if it makes sense.
If you have a legend,
you have to in the legend.
All of these information
has to be there
in the plot.
If you miss any of those,
that means you will
get zero because it's
a partially erlot We
have a few examples here.
Now, you can see here
the exxs is title,
y axis is titled,
and then the title of the
title of the
plot is missing,
but you need to add all of
those information
in the plot,
we have another
band in some of.
This basically does not
name the axis
meaningfully.
So please avoid
these things and
then make sure
that the plot
title access titles,
consistent axis
labels, legend
and everything,
whatever applicable
to your plot is.
Now, the second part,
data ranking. So,
For this one,
clearly identifies
all problematic
data points
across all three factors,
including specific dates,
provides a
structure table,
detailing issue
time date and
justification for
those trading methods.
Data ranging, if
you remember,
we talked about
how you handle
cata as well as
the outliers and
you use different
methods to handle
the and whatever
the method you
choose for that particular
problematic data,
you say one is the
method you use and then
you have to justify.
The justification
would be different
from one person
to another based on
the method tissue,
but then it has
to be reasonable.
For an example, if you
say if you have data,
let's say for example,
if you're doing
some social
behavioural analysis
and then if
you're looking at
the amount of passengers
that case cross to Roma
straight railway
station on
certain days
where there are
maintenance during
weekdays or
school holidays
with senior,
zero or the amount of
people would go very low.
When you look at
the plots and when
you look at the
line plots or boxplots,
you will see them
as outliers.
Then maybe because
you are considering
social human interaction
in that case,
when it is closed, it
does not make sens.
If you Google them, you
Google those dates,
you will find those close
for maintenance dates,
and you can decide
to remove them.
Those justifications
you need to
give in order
to say how you
and the data missing
ali based on whatever
the method you.
This is the stable that
you will be filling.
And this is
basically what I
discussed how you
intend to handle the
problematic data
identify you put here.
Basically, you say what is
the best handling
mechanism.
Don't just say
removing outliers,
so you will not
get full mark
in those vague answers.
Say for missing data u
and explain why it is.
If you use mean to
sa and elaborate,
you explain For example,
if you take temperature
all over the year.
Some during not
not maybe sm,
but if you take maybe
like Melbourne.
So during winter
the average and
during
summer average would
be entirely different,
so it's seasonally,
they change.
And then if you want to
replace the
date in winter,
it makes more
sense to compute
the average in
those season,
you define the
season and then
you average fine the
average and replace
imputed that rather
than saying you want
to use the whole
me, right?
And also, in terms
of removing,
for example, if
you're removing the
data. If you are
analysing how
QUT number of people
coming and going
out of QUT,
you will find nice spikes
on weekdays and weekends
it would go down,
and then on a particular
Sunday it would go up.
To a certain sky
rocket day because
it's open day and
a lot of people
who come in.
In that case, the way
how you deal with it
is depends on how
you plan to do
whatever you.
If you think you
want to remove it,
it's a once in
a year event
that does not
reflect anything.
You remove it.
If you're using for
any resource planning
or water management
or electricity management,
something like that,
then you might
probably keep it because
it's an actual event.
It's not a job missing
sensor information or
something like that.
Based on I think that's
straightforward.
Now the next part
is in the template,
it says use up to
three examples
for each proble type
within each bikeway.
What we mean by
problem type is,
it can be outliers
missing data or
errors for each bikeway
that is defined here.
If you find more than
the instances exist,
report only three,
if f exist,
report all that
you can find.
If you have
more than three
for each problem type,
you can have three.
And then if you
have less than
the only number of
occurrences you
find, you report.
I think that's
straightforward as well.
In some cases,
missing data is
consecutive 45 days and
if you are planning to
handle it the same way,
you can define it as a
range rather than having
those as different columns
and repeating
the same again.
So but you cannot put
for a long range.
You can say I'm
deleting all,
so that's not sensible,
so I hope that part is.
I think I explained
this one.
Interesting cases.
Outliers doesn't
always mean
that you need
to remove them.
First, consider whether
the behaviour in
the data is explainable
in addition to
the boxplots,
take a look at the
line plot to see if
there are any other
consistent patters.
Check if there
are signs of
ors in measurements
or sensors.
If you remember the
example that we discussed
a week ago we have
multiple sensor readings.
If one sensor value
suddenly goes down and
the other sensor
value goes
up and if they
are correlated,
that means it's not
a sensor failure.
There is some
event that has oc.
So similarly, so you could
look at the other
sets of values
in those cases and come to
a conclusion if
all the sense
information is missing,
then it could probably be
a maintenance or site
being closed,
something like that.
If you remember, the water
management plant
example we discussed.
We had a few variables.
So it talks
about that here.
Then you can also search
online for any ev.
This is what I
meant like a
bridge closure
or something.
You see the data
being extremely low,
you Google and you find
the bridge is
being closed on
a particular data sort
explains why the
pattern has happened.
Based on this, you can
make an information
whether
or not to keep the data
points in your analysis.
I totally depends on you,
based on your
justification.
Next part is
supporting evidence.
As we explained
earlier itself,
you can use Excel Python
or Macle to do
this analysis.
If you look at the Canvas,
there are videos
individually
created for all those
free path platforms,
so you can go
through them.
We have the
resources there.
Then when you do
use one of those,
you have to upload
the supporting
evidence the do.
The main thing is
if you're doing
Mt la Python, it's a
bit straightforward.
You can export the
live script as
a VF and attach it
as an appendix.
If it is Python
notebook, again,
you can export
the notebook
as a PDF and attach it.
But the things become
interesting if
you're doing it with
Excel because
you do clicks.
We include
your supporting evidence
in the appendix.
Copy and paste
the code into
the document if you're
using live script,
M the document PDF.
Fix pot and Live ScaF.
But these are some
examples and with Excel,
what happens is you're
doing the clicks
and they disappear.
Just show where you get
the information
or where you
get the particular
plot from.
Like as Shi sing
this example.
And you don't have
to for example,
if you are growing
three block spots,
the s are the same,
so you don't have to
take three different
screen shots to show that
so you can show one
and say the same
process followed,
and then you can show the
plot generator
at last, maybe.
So any sensible method
to show the
evidence is fine.
So for Excel this
way is to get
some screenshots.
These are some examples
here. All right. So
The next part is
using the correct
version of the data set.
I think I
explained this on
the starting part of
data analysis as well.
If you go through
the assignment
details page,
there are four
different data sets,
basically, two clean and
then two row versions.
For each section, you will
be using those
different data sets.
For Section one, you use
the row set that
we have given.
For Section 23 onwards,
for Section two and three,
you use the clean
versions we give.
Don't use the versions
that you clean,
use the clean versions.
Another thing,
the reason why we
do it is because
there could
be multiple ways you
would be handling or
angling your data based
on the justification
you have.
And then it would be
inconsistent among
everyone and
it becomes very hard to
mark if you do
it on your own.
That's why we gave
a clean version.
Be careful the
version we have clean
is not the expected answer
that you would
get if you clean.
I mean, you could not
just reverse engineer.
It doesn't make
sense in that case.
Don't worry if it is
different, right?
In section, you do
the correlation,
so you find correlation
between variables
and you report them
that straightforward.
Here in correlation
analysis interpretation.
In some cases, you might
see these clusters.
As we discussed last week,
when you see
these clusters,
per and correlation
coefficient
if you look at
the equation,
it uses mean with
every observant
to calculate
the correlation
coefficient,
when you have
clusters like this,
it impacts the mean,
which means it
impacts the p
and correlation
coefficient you're
going to get.
One of the meaningful way
is to remove the clusters,
separate them using
one variable.
For the example I took
earlier like weekdays and
weekends of how many
people come in to QUT,
you would see clearly
two different clusters.
You can separate it
using days and then take
the weekdays
separately and
weekend separately
to the correlation.
Otherwise, the
correlation coefficient
would not make sense
in some cases.
So general observations,
what you see in the loss,
and then reason
explanation,
hypothesis observation,
what do they aipply?
Seasonal variations,
demographics, and
references, again.
If you take the
temperature example,
you will see different
clusters based on Cs.
And then what does the
correlation co plus.
An interesting case is
if you look at this plot.
So you have visual
a positive correlation
in this cluster.
You have almost a positive
correlation in
this cluster,
but the coefficients
a negative value.
This does not reflect
what we see in the plot.
The discussion
along this line
and then how you would
do it is what is
expected in most
of those cases.
Look at the questions and
the lubric the
interpretation part,
interpret those
things correctly.
All right. Finally,
for Section three,
you do multiple linear
regulation analysis.
We discussed this in
detail last week,
but if I give
a quick brief,
you are doing multiple
linear regulation
analysis means
analysis can
be done with
multiple varies.
You're going to use
multiple variables.
If you take a generic
linear equation,
it's like
For two variables,
one independent
one independent,
is y equal in x plus
C. But when you have
more variables,
it becomes y equal m1x1
plus two x two plus
three x plus whatever n
c. If it is two variables,
it's easy, it's
a straight line,
but more the
variables become,
the distant
boundaries become
for example, if it
is three dimension
three variable,
then it's a claim.
If it is n dimensions,
then it's a hyperplane,
that's the.
You don't have to worry
about it too much.
The understanding is you
find for multiple
gation analysis.
You use all the variables
and do the regation,
and see what are
statistically
significant and
insignificant.
You use the p values and
squares and all these to
compare it and then
fit the base model.
In all machine learning
mostly regation is one
of the pratical example
of a machine
learning model.
In all machine learning,
we use the data
to train a model.
So when we use the
DR data model,
you split them into
two different sets.
One is the train
set test set.
You fit the model using
the train dataset,
and then you see how well
your model is doing
using the test set,
which is not used
during training.
You follow the
same procedure.
You use the train data
set and use these values,
r square values to
see and find
the base model.
Then once you have
your base model,
you test it on
the test data set
that the compute
the test matrices
like root speed
square t or RMC.
Here in this case,
you have to
keep the RMC on
both train and
test data sets and
comb the and discuss
that, right?
Important points is yes,
we've given the instructions
to separate it.
So from January 1,
2024 to December 31,
2017, inclusive
is the train set,
and the remaining
data is the test set.
Make sure you
spread it this
given on this
correct given dates.
Otherwise, the answers
would differ, right?
I think those are
the parts to highlight
in this slide.
Do not create
separate recreation
models for each.
Just don't take
two variables,
all of those two
variables and
create separate reation
models for those.
What we expect
is instead build
a single reation
model that includes
all identified
independent variables.
You may need to repeat
the ration modelling
process until
all variables have
statistically
significant v. This
is straightforward,
This is what I
discussed earlier.
And provide summary
module table,
recreation summary
table should
be generated on
the training data.
RMS should be reported
based on train
and test plays,
and you have to generate
the scatter blocks using
the training data.
For the
interpretation parts,
provides a clear well
structured interpretation
of both the
region models, use
appropriate
reation outputs
to justify the conclusion.
Here, you need to use
the statistical matrices
like the statistic
square basics,
how much of variable
in the data is
captured by the model.
You use the p value to see
the statistical
significance of
that variable.
You use all those
information and describe
the trends you see and
everything you see on
the data and your
interpretation.
It has to be a good
rigorous interpretation
rather than just
explaining the numbers.
That's what expected
in this file.
When it comes to
Section four,
you do either A or
P. This is what
we discussed at
the beginning.
Part A is you
try your best to
locate a publicly
available data.
That's the highly
encouraged one.
In a worst case, if
you don't find one,
you can use the synthetic
data generation based
on how we generated
one in the beginning
of the class.
You should use
the same research
topic from Assignment one,
so that's a high part
to find the variables for
synthetic data
generation and for
your assignment project
page presentation.
In this case,
why we say use
the same topics
because when
you're generating data for
the topic, certain
variables,
as I explained earlier,
the ranges and everything
you can pick from
the leg. Does that
Finally, you do a
correlation analysis using
the preliminary data
and then you explain
it basically
interpret it as well.
In these cases, you might
find some interesting
analysis.
If you use a
real world data,
you might see the
actual applications.
As I mentioned
earlier synthetic
data might not give
certain obvious
correlations
because it's random.
In that case, it's
okay you discuss
it in detail.
Those are the
main things that
I had to cover in
terms of the
assignment tool.
Now Any questions
on these slides?
But may have?
No. All right.
So now we can maybe
I can come to
you and answer
your questions
and Stay also
can come and answer
the questions.
All right. Thank you.